大家好,我是Yoni,那很开心呢,今天又以这样直播的形式跟大家见面了,那今天呢,咱们是继上一次,又邀请到了海外机构DCP的联合创始人王一鸣老师,那一鸣老师呢,本身也是深耕量化快20年了,那他们机构的管理规模本身也已经超了12亿美金,那一鸣老师呢,以前呢,是在骑士资本,此前呢,也受邀在国内一些高校做过讲座,那今天呢,是因为上一次,我邀请一鸣老师做了这个基于机器学习构建量化交易模型全能程拆解,
这样的一个主题分享之后,那有很多小伙伴呢,其实都在私心问我相关线下课程的问题,所以呢,今天又是特地邀请到了一鸣老师来专门为小伙伴们进行关于这个线下课程的一个课前答疑,那接下来呢,我就先把时间先交到给一鸣老师,一鸣老师。
OK,那个大家好啊,王一鸣,因为你刚才也讲了哈,因为之前是做过一次那个关于这个机器学习构建量化模型的这个流程的拆解的主题分享啊,然后可能有很多小伙伴有很多问题啊,因为就是因为我们下个月正好是六月份是在国内有那个相关的课程,对,所以大家如果待会有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有那个相关的课程,对,所以大家如果待会有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有那个相关的课程,对,所以大家如果待会有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有那个相关的课程,对,所以大家
或者是这个在那个聊天的那个里面直接把问题那个打出来也可以哈,然后我们继续哈,嗯,是这样的,呃,就是关于整个的这个,呃,就是机器学习的这个框架呢,然后是这样的,我想分几个内容先给大家再讲一下哈,讲完之后呢,然后针对我们线下课程的核心的价值和内和那个相关的课程,对,所以大家如果待会有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内有什么针对课程有问题的话,可以直接上麦哈,或者是在国内
相关的内容,然后再深入的再讲一下,对,然后这边分几个部分哈,那第一呢,就是说我们整个量化策略的一个大的一个框架哈,另外呢,就是说因为涉及到不同的这个,呃,量化策略的设计,对,所以呢,每一种量化策略呢,它的第一,就是第一性原理是什么哈,第二呢,就是说,嗯,第三呢,就是说基于这个整个motion learning的这个,就是机器学习的技术路径的全链路的一个规划,
对,然后第四呢,是针对国内的这个商品期货,还有股票的ETF,还有像,呃,crypto加密货币,呃,一个市政的一个研究哈,最后是这个相关课程的内容,对,然后我们先看一下哈,因为,嗯,我也看了很多国内的这个,嗯,讲量化的这个相关的课程,对,就是基本上可能是大家在因子方面,或者在这个复现研报方面的比较多,
但是其实整个的,嗯,量化的框架其实需要大家有一个,嗯,全局的一个视角哈,就不仅仅是在某一两个环节,对,然后所以说,我们先把这个大概的这个量化的框架先了解一下哈,那大家肯定在市面上听到很多像,什么趋势啊,套利啊,中性啊,什么,呃,轮动啊,什么指增啊,像这类的策略哈,其实我爱护都是这种,嗯,像是,
嗯,时序啊,或是截面,两大类的这个策略组成的哈,那截面的其实,嗯,是比这个时序要多一个维度哈,因为时序,比如说我们对单一品种进行这个研究,肯定是基于它是自相关的吧,对,那,那么截面的可能会是在这个单一品种的这个时序特征的基础上,然后进行了相关的这种排序,或者叫比较哈,那产生了一些,
比如说某某种风,某那个怎样的这种风格,然后来赚取这种风格的钱啊,那与此同时呢,整个量化呢,其实从最早的这种线性的规则类,慢慢的转为这种比如特征啊,呃,多因子的这种框架,那当下呢,很多的这种海外啊,以及国内的机构也都慢慢的转向了这个机器学习的这种技术路,这是这种技术路径哈,因为,嗯,坦率讲,嗯,嗯,其实如果,
如果是基于最早的这种,呃,ZPM,就是资本资产定价模型来讲的话,其实,嗯,这个传统的金融理论其实缺乏了,呃,特征之间,或者叫做因子之间的这种C线性结构的这种研究哈,那么传统的金融框架基本上都是孤立的哈,比如说对单一特征,或者叫做对单一因子进行检验,但是缺乏了这个因子和因子,或者叫特征和特征之间的这种C线性结构,
关系的研究,那当下其实机器学习就是很好了,很好的补充了传统金融理论的这么一个缺失的这个板块,嗯,那针对不同的策略呢,其实我们要清楚我们相关要赚到市场上怎样的钱哈,对,那这五个策略呢,其实就是比较常见的哈,也相对比较主流哈,那第一呢,比如说是像这种军事型策略,那我们知道其实他是在赚这个相关的钱哈,那简单的来讲,
的话其实也就是说赚这个市场惯性的这个钱,比如说的上涨的话,可能是不是一直在上涨,那下跌的话呢,会不会一直下跌哈,对,那正常的这种金融标的呢,其实都是有很强的这种相关性,那所以呢,我们在做趋势策略的时候,其实也很容易能拿到这部分的这个利润哈,但是呢,这个大家可以看到第二个这种策略,比如说军事回归,那军事回归呢,其实就是和这个趋势策略,
相互互补哈,因为有趋势就要有回归,那比如说我们在某一个标的涨到一定价格的时候,他可能会回归到某一个数学上的一个负值,对,然后呢,如果这个他可能是在频繁的这个负值之间来宽差哈,那如果这样的话呢,那其实我们可以在某种情况下做相应的这种均值回归的这种策略,那也就是说我们的这个价格和价值,
他其实是,
在不断的这种偏离修复在这种循环,对,但是其实最难的是什么,最难的其实就是我们如何把这个趋势和震荡分开哈,那其实这个,因为现有的这种模型可能都会存在相应的这种叫我们叫边界效应,也就是说对于当前的状态其实很难判断,可能有的小伙伴会会问啊,那那比如说我们看这个配线图,那他是上涨还是下跌,那其实我们用这个,
眼睛一看其实是就能判清的,那为什么这个模型判断当前的状态会很难哈,那其实是这个样子哈,因为我们人眼看到其实这个也不是他当前的这个状态,因为他是其实你看到的已经是发生过的哈,也就是说我们用现有的所有的这种,
呃,除了用这种引波来表达特来表达这个市场的特征之外,其实我们所有的数据也都是滞后的哈,那我们再来看这个截面策略哈,
那截面策略其实是在时序的基础上,那加了一个相对的一个比较或者是排序哈,更多的是用在这种,
嗯,比如说对这个股票市场是用的是最多的,那当然说时序和截面会很好的这种结合哈,那因此其实我们的课程也都是先从时序来开始讲,
然后最后呢,以这个,嗯,比如说进阶课,然后截面课最后再讲到配置哈,对,那所以大家可以看到,那我们对时序了,
对时序策略,嗯,了解之后,其实对截面再展开相关的研究,其实就会容易很多哈,
那除了这个趋势啊,均值回归截面,那还有相应的这个套利的这个策略哈,那套利的策略,我记得之前也做过一期,专门做过一期是套利,是用,嗯,趋势的方式做套利哈,
就是完全不同的,嗯,这种框架,那其实套利策略基本上和上面提到的这个第二,第二个均值回归的这个策略,
点点类似哈,那只是单纯的均值回归呢,可能是在某某一个标的上来做,那套利呢,其实我们会找到,比如说,嗯,嗯,一对这个标的,或者是,嗯,更多的这种套利的标的来统一进行这种计算哈,
那所以我们要知道这个套利,其实这个大家也都知道套利的这个策略,其实相关的风险还是偏低的,因为它基本上,嗯,用现有的这种方式,
比如说像是这种,
嗯,嗯,嗯,传统的这种统计的方法来做的话,其实这个风险度还是相当可控的,那当然说也可以用我之前讲到的这个不一样的这个套利策略来做哈,相当于是我们套利的策略,其实就完全变成了这个,嗯,趋势性策略了哈,那是另外的一种特别方式哈,对,那最后呢,其实就是和波动率策略相关的,基本上可能这部分策略更多的是在,嗯,风险对空以及做这个,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,嗯,
嗯,套利啊,或者是齐全相关的这个,嗯,平面上,对,那更多的其实我们看到更多的其实还是这个趋势策略以及这个截面策略哈,那其他的比如说像君子回归啊,套利啊,这个都是类似的哈,那波动率策略呢,更多的可能是给我们截面或者是趋势策略做这个风险对冲用的哈,对,但是我们要清楚哈,那每种策略其实赚的是不同的金钱哈,这点是很关键的。
然后因为一到机器学习的话呢
其实它的技术入境还是这个蛮长的
对它不太像其他的
比如说规则类的一些方法
相对比较简单单纯
那机器学习因为
它是完全是复学逻辑
然后找到特征和特征之间的
这种非线性关系
那所以呢
我们希望在这个数据处理的
或者叫做数据分析数据处理的
这个环节其实就可以让这个数据
变得更具有统计意义
那所以呢
我们的课程也是从这个全链路规划来触发
那也是希望大家能够
从平时零零散散的这些片面的知识
能够把所有的这个全站的技术
能够串起来
那所以呢
我们课程也是针对这个整体来统筹
然后分布来实施的这么一个方式
然后也是希望呢
打破这个像
i
t
数数学
以及金融的这种学科的壁垒
毕竟
这个基于这个机器学习的这个量化的模型的设计
其实是需要跨学科的这种能力的
那所以我们这边给大家看到的全链路规划
其实也就是说我们课程上会详细讲到的一些环节
那当然说这里边也有很多我们没有写出来的内容
那这个制定一轴的这个重新
采样和时间轴的对比
其实这个是我
对习惯性要讲的这个内容哈
因为我们要知道
因为我们后续是要用机器学习来训练模型的
所以前期的这个布局处理的
我们希望他可以更具有统计特性一些哈
那右边的这个图其实就是我们传统意义上的这个时间维度的这个一阶差分的这个概率分布哈
大家可以看到那个虚线的部分是正态的哈
那红色的部分是一阶差分之后的概率分布
大家可以看到其实他们的这个峰值其实还是蛮高的哈
就峰值我在课上会证明给大家看哈
那这个峰值其实变相就代表的是我们的这个市场震荡的这个频次哈
那也就是说你在尾部赚到的钱
其实基本上会在这个峰值的这个部分会亏掉哈
那也就是说
比如说你在一个长的一个上涨
或者说你在一个长的一个上涨
或者是下跌的这个趋势中赚到了钱
那比如说我们在进入震荡的时候
其实你会发现
比如说你刚做多的时候
那其实你是行情可能又下来了哈
那下来之后你做空之后
然后这个行情又上涨
就经常会有这种情况的来回被来回被洗
所以我们知道一看到这个图的话
其实我们就很清楚哈
那假设在这种不具有统计意义的这种分布上面来进行策略设计的话
其实是很难的哈
对啊
基本上啊
基本上也赚不到太多的这个钱
因为尾部赚到的钱其实都会在这个部分来亏亏掉啊
那同样呢
其实我们建议大家还是进行这种对市场的这个数据进行重采样
然后变成我们自定义的这个维度的这个轴啊
那当然说这个是给大家举了一个简单的一个例子哈
这个是用成交额来做的哈
那大家可以看到这个在配线也就是半的数量
将相相差不多的情况下
就相似的情况下
其实我们我们的这个呃
加率分布会更接近于正台哈
更接近于正态
其实是嗯
是不嗯
是这个我们在调整完重采样之后是附加的这个价值
对其实我们的核心是要满足我们每一个bar内部的这个信息密度更均匀啊
也就是说为我们后面积极学习的这个训练呃的这个baseline
然后做了很好的这个数据复旅的这个训练啊
就准备了
那其实这个也是我们在无论是在做截面还是在做时序呃的时候
策略的设计的时候的第一步哈
那呃
如果是我们采用这种呃
有监督的这个机器学习的技术路线的话
那其实我们都避不开
我们要对于市场的数据进行标注哈
那这里边我们是用这个概率聚类的方式呃
来做这个数据呃
数学层面上的一个标注哈
因为传统的标注
比如说
你用这个未来的收益啊
或者是你上涨就标一下下下跌就不要复一或者是标零的话
那其实这种方式是不具有统计意义
不是不太具有统计意义的哈
因为我们要知道
因为我们交易的时候
其实是如果我们做嗯
假设我们做趋势性策略的设计的话
那我们希望那他上涨的这个过程中的这个有一些小的回调
其实是对我们没有产生什么影响的哈
希望我们的这个持仓是连续的
那所以一句嗯
更这个嗯
落地的这种交易相结合的话
那其实我希望是进行这种趋势性标签的这种标注哈
那这个也是嗯嗯
就是进入到后面的这个有监督的这个呃模型训练的一个这个其实就是我们的外哈
也就是说我们的这个标签对那在标签做完之后呢
当然说我们还有呃相应的这个特征工程哈
那这里边呢
展示的大家其实看到的就是我们
不叠的呃
一些的这个特征哈
大家可以看到这个呃
比如是变相进行的这个变相进行的这个标准化哈
之后的这个特征的矩阵
那这个我们会用这个这个其实就是我们的x哈
那我们会用这个特征去学习到那个标签哈
嗯
在呃
当然说这个之前也做过一些对比哈
那右面的这个其实就是呃
我们在对时间轴就没有进行呃
数据从采样的呃
数据进行这个模型训练之后
就是所有的步骤都一致的情况下
那其实我们看到他的这个呃收益啊
然后最大回撤卡码
包括我们的这个回撤面积
其实都要比这个从采样之后的这个自定义轴的这个要弱很多哈
当然说我们嗯
其实训练的方式也完全也是相同的
包括用降维的方式也都是相同的
那左边大家可以看到
那我们在做单一模型训练完之后呢
然后我们会进行相应的这种
组合哈
那组合之后的这个收益还是蛮可观的
对那后面有几个图哈
那这个其实是针对这个他们期货啊
因为国内的上级货呃是更接近于海外哈
那我们也可以做多
也可以做空哈
那大家看到这是差不多25个月的数据吧
对训练完之后做完的模型组合
差不多是呃收益总的收益是这个67.81哈
然后这个这个嗯
最大回撤是5.78
卡码是在5以上哈
然后DA是我们自己的这个指标
有这个课程会给大家代码哈
也就是说我们的这个橘色的
这个回撤面积哈
其实这个回撤面积还是蛮关键的
因为它代表的其实就是我们
交易者或者是你的资方的一个心理阴影的面积哈
对那这个回撤面积越小
其实代表我们的这个回补期会更快哈
对那个这是RB的这个数据
因为国内的这个RB是多空都可以做哈
那同样呢
我们对这个国内的护身300的ETF也进行了模型的训练哈
那这个其实就是呃这个收益是107哈
最最大回撤是15.69
卡码是5.49
这个回撤面积会更小一点哈
这是进行了15个月的这个测试
其实涵盖了这个从15年前年到到这个今年的这个三月底哈
大家可以看到这基本上这个该吃的这个趋势其实都知道啊
该
该亏损的部分的其实都是没有持仓的哈
因为国内的这个ETF其实是我们没有办法做空哈
所以我们只能是单边做多的这么一种方式哈
另外呢
还有对这个ETA上哈
Crypto的这个加密货币的这个做了一个相应的这个模型的训练
这个收益是81哈
最大回撤15卡码也是在5以上哈
那回撤面积是86.53哈
因为嗯
Crypto特别是ETH啊
像BTC这类的
Crypto的品种的话
他因为他的这个呃波动还是蛮大对
所以呢
在做这个像单一呃标的的时候呢
我们其实还是建议呃大家可以把很多的这个标的来同时来做哈
那同时做很多标的的话
其实能够相对相对应的能对冲掉相应的这个之间的这个风险哈
然后前面的是简单的给大家过了一下哈
因为很多的内容是涉及到这个
嗯
线下课
就是线下课的这个里的内容的
因为在这个公开的这个主题分享的时候
可能我就不太方便来讲了哈
因为我们要对这个之前这个上过线下课的小伙伴要负责哈
对那我在讲一下这个相应的其实课里的这个核心的意义哈
那第一呢
其实我们希望是大家能够和有这种全站的能力哈
那也就是说从你开始的一个数据复理哦
这个重彩样子的定义轴
然后标签啊
特征降维训练回测评估组合
推理石盘等等
那其实我们希望是
大家能够掌握整个的全流程
因为坦率讲
这个量化这个行业
因为离前太近了
所以这个有很多时候
比如说大家零零散散
看到一些内容
可能有的时候会很难串起来
对那所以呢
这个第一呢
我们觉得是能够把全站的这种方式
能够和大家来公开
那其实对于大家来讲的话
那其实就是完全是非常干的干货
第二呢
是这个希望大家能够从
这个整个的pipeline里边
能理会到更多的是思维方式
因为有的时候我们觉得
技术可能不是最重要的
因为有现在有这个
比如说有AI啊
然后大家可以让这个
大语言模型来辅助我们
来写一些代码什么的
但是其实你发现
如果你没有好的这个思路
或者叫
你没有整整个统筹的一个认知的话
那其实你用AI
它给到的结果也都是比较一般的
对所以说最重要的还是还是希望
大家能够从课程当中
能够学到很多的这个课程方式
对以及处理技术问题的一些个
细节的方法和想法
那第三呢
其实是让大家能够
在量化的过程中
能够打破一些壁垒
因为我们更多的是
讲的是数学逻辑
其实因为参加过课程的小伙伴
可能会比较清楚
就是我们基本上和金融相关的内容很少
就基本上是没有完全是
不学逻辑
因为我们清楚这个很多在模型训练的时候
因为模型它对你是哪个行业
它是不清楚的
那它完全是这种不学逻辑
所以所以呢
我们从这个每一个环节
其实都是会用数学的方式
来进行相应的这个复理哈
对
那其实大家也能够体会到
因为我们机器学习
其实不仅仅是模型训练的那一个环节
用这个方式哈
那其实我们在很多环节也都有会把一些
有监督或者是无监督的这种
这个机器学习的方法
用到我们
其实一些各个环节当中
那最后呢
其实也是希望大家能够通过课程
能够能够自主的其实训练模型
是团拜了基本上全市场所有的这个标的哈
那希望大家能够就是那无论是做国内的标的
还是海外的这个标的
无论是多空同时做还是这个只能够做多哈
那其实都可以用我们的这个
用我们的这个生产线的技术框架来实现了
那其实这个就是我们的课程的主要的这个价值哈
对另外呢
就是这两页其实就是我们课程的大纲哈
因为之前
有很多小伙伴其实我都会比较清楚
他们看到这个大纲之后
可能就会想自己想办法去复现
其实我倒是建议大家
其实如果是有能力复现的话
也可以复现
但是其实这里面面临很多的这种细节的问题
因为我们还是建议大家能够参加我们的线下课
虽然说我们不是专业讲课的
我们也不做国内的市场
其实反而会更愿意讲一些干货
因为我们和大家没有直接的冲突
我帮大家把课程的内容换一下
待会大家如果有问题的话
直接就可以上麦
或者是把文字打出来也可以
第一我们既然是要讲机器学习
在整个的量化模型的全流程中的
应用
其实我们机器学习也是作为我们的一个基础
比如说我们哪类的模型是能够用的
哪类的模型是我们没有办法使用的
另外就是说一些思维方式
我觉得这是最关键的
其实这个也是机器学习讲的内容
第二个部分其实就是数据的复语
获取以及分析
因为很多时候我们在做模型之前
其实很少会对数据
进行相应的这种分析和处理
可能拿到数据直接就打标签
可能直接就进行模型训练
其实重点都在模型调餐上
其实是这样的
其实我们的数据处理能力
其实是整个机器学习的
能够得到很好结果的一个天花板
也就是说你数据处理能力的好
其实你的后续训练出来的结果也会很好
也就是说你前期可能没有这些动作的话
你后边大概率的模型也是没有办法用的
另外也是我们的第三个环节
其实就是我们对市场的数据进行了重采样
刚才也给大家看到一个采样方式
其实很多就是多种多样
但是说重点是方法论
不是说是我们非要接近于正态等等
其实我们要知道每一个环节背后的核心的逻辑
大家看到的它接近于正态程度
那都是表象
重点是它背后的逻辑
第四项其实就是我们要对数据进行相应的标注
因为我们后面是做有监督的模型训练
所以要对数据进行相应的标注
不同的标注方法
其实也会影响到我们模型的训练
其实大家可以看到
其实我们每一个环节和环节之间都是相通的
然后相互之间它是有协同意义的
并不是说独立的
比如说我做完A就做B做完B就做C
其实我们是有关联的
那也就是说比如说我们在下
就是比如说我们在后面的几步
然后比如说它在对前边
就是前边的一些参数的调整
其实对我们后面的这个步骤
其实是有直接的关联的
这一点是很重要
这一点也是希望能够在课程上
让大家能够体会到
也就是说除了这种全局的这种视角以外
希望大家能够更深刻的理解
就是每个环节之间的这种协同逻辑
然后像第五个环节特征
然后以及比如说布局降维
然后其实这两个是可以是结合在一起
那目的是把我们的大量的这个
比如说有噪音
或者是有这种贡献性问题的这个特征
能够把维度能够降
能够降下来
那降维呢
我们也会讲线性和非线性
那当然说线性的里面会会有很多的这个石盘操作的时候的坑
那我们如何规避
我们也会都会非常详细的讲
那后面呢
就是说涉及到这个模型训练
以及这个模型的专用性和通用性的这个问题
那最后呢
涉及到这个模型的组合
以及这个模型的规理和石盘的交易
大家可能会误认为
比如说我模型训练完之后
可能就代表着我大部分99的工作已经做完了
那其实是不是这样
因为模型训练之后可能仅仅完成了一半的工作
那更多的挑战其实都会在模型的组合
以及在这个推理和石盘的交易中
那这里边会大家会遇到很多种各种各样的这个问题
那我们在课程上也会详细的带着大家把这个流程跑通
所以大家可以看到
那其实是我们前面
就是这个图就是会讲的比较清楚
其实大家可以体会到
那其实我们是在讲一个全链路的一个规划
然后目的是让大家有这种统筹的视角
以及会清楚各个环节之间的这种协同的逻辑
他并不是说是独立的
对这个是最关键
那也希望的是我们六月份的线下的课程的能够给大家带来一个不一样的感受
对
那看看
这个我的这个简单的介绍就到这里哈
看看大家有没有关于课程想问的一些问题
打在那个聊天的那里边也可以
或者是直接连麦都可以哈
OK
谢谢你们老师的讲解哈
那咱们今天的小伙伴
就是因为我想大概今天来参加小伙伴都是之前有跟我这边简单的有了解过
这个咱们的一个课程大纲的
因为我不知道大家可能还会有一些细节性的问题
所以说呢
今天就正好
就是让一秒是这边专门抽出时间来给大家做这样的一个课前答疑
对所以说大家如果有什么问题
因为之前一秒是也做过好几次这个呃就是公开课了
那大家可能也都有看过
所以说呢
就大家可以有啥问题都可以上麦来直接提问哈
因为机会比较难得
然后因为一秒是他们本身机构管理规模也还是挺大的
对所以这个我觉得机会确实比较难得
对所以说看大家问题就可以提问好吗
对哎一秒
是我想问两个问题
就一个是关于那个自定义轴的一个是关于这个标签的
然后我在那个消息框里发了一个pdf
那个是我初步浮现了一下
然后做了些实验
然后我第一个问题是关于自定义轴的就是我发现就是呃自定义轴不打开了哈
然后这个文件
因为我要展示这个供那个共享屏幕
然后我就不打开了
然后你直接问就可以了
行
就是第一个问题是关于自定义轴的
我就是我发现他这个就是统计意义上这个风度还有这个就是在就是均值零附近的一c个码的这个位置上的这个比例
然后还有就是这个瓣的数量就是往往不能见得就是尤其是我想要一个比较大的一个瓣的数量的话
他往往就是在中间就是正负零点五c个码那个位置上的那个瓣的比例
会
这个变高
所以这块
怎么去平衡这个瓣的数量以及中间的这个风度
而且我在很多etf上会发现一些肥伟的现象
然后是不是对于这种趋势性的策略肥伟是可以允许的
也就是这个风度客
就是传统意义上的这个风度大一些
其实无所谓
只要把中间的这个一c个码位置里面的这个就是瓣的比例给他降下来就可以了
这个是那个第一个问题
就是关于自定义轴
然后第二个问题是关于那个标签
就是非监督去生成标签的这么一个问题
也是做了一些实验
也是基于一些美股的一些这个etf
然后我的问题是
就是就是公开就是视频里说
就是最好标签的这个均值要趋劲零点五后面比较好训练
这个我在etf上会发现我做出来的标签
大概在零点七附近
就是那个均值在零点七附近
因为他是有肯定是有一个那个往上走的一个趋势嘛
所以就是我需要在这个标签生成的阶段就给他压到零点五合适呢
还是说我在那个训练的阶段用一些这个后采样的方法去把这个标签压到零点五附近会比较好呢
就是一个是我我通过比如说调整HMM的这个
尹马可夫的这个里面的各种参数
然后来压到零点五还是这个做后处比较好
因为这个数据本身他就有一定的这个趋势性
所以就是做在前面在前面做这个label balance
还是在后边做就是在蒙尼训练的时候做比较好
是我的这两个问题
OK因为涉及到了很多的这个我们课程上是要讲的内容哈
然后我只能是就是稍微大概的回答你一下哈
然后也还是建议你
来参加那个我们线下的课哈
那第一个就是标签的那个第一个是这个重采样轴的那个问题其实是这样的
因为呃我不知道你的那个方式哈
因为比如我大概率能猜到你是比如说用AI辅助写的这个代码什么的
因为其实我们还是保持着这种呃传统的这种呃我们自己来写代码的这种方式哈
就是说是我们比如说如果我们借助AI的话
可能会是在
嗯一些这个呃比如说把我们的代码减量啊的方式上会用到这个AI
但是主要核心的这个内容其实还是我们自己来写
这个是比较呃关键的哈
所以说我我是觉得可能做这边一轴的那个方式
其实和我们要讲的方式可能还有很大的这个区别
对那这是第一哈
第二就是你刚才提到的这个风度啊
包括这个呃这个就是导体啊
就是导节的这个呃数量的方式
其实坦率讲这个因为我不能多说哈
希望你能理理解哈
因为涉及到这个很多课程上的一些嗯细节
因为要对对对得起这个之前上过课的这些个小伙伴哈
对那这个那那这是关于自定义轴哈
另外呢就是说你刚才提到的这个嗯嗯这个标签哈
那标签呢
其实这个方法有很多对
然后你提到的
这个呃方式呢
其实我们不会用对
然后只是可能这样
因为你刚才提到了那个也马可福哈
那我其实我我们会呃会间接的来用它
但是不是直接来用哈
对这个我只能说到这了
对然后这个因为也马可福有他自己的这个呃
计算的这个呃逻辑的这种局限性
对然后呢
这个呃呃标签的这个呃呃数值呢
这个问题呢
其实比较好解决
因为嗯这个我能大概给你讲
讲一下哈
也就是说你的那个呃零点七的话
其实是因为有很多品种呃坦率讲
他是只适合做多的哈
只适合做多的不适合做空对有的品种呢
是适合多空都做
有的品种只适合做多哈
对所有所以呢
像是这类的呃这个呃这个标的呢
可能大概率我们建议建议就是做多对
就是只做多会会更容易一些
那特别像是这种像呃QQQ啊
TQQQ啊
就是像这类的和美股这种相关的ETF的话
包括黄金啊等等
其实他是适合只做多的哈
对那其实这点也也是呃很很重要的
对因为我如果不说的话
你可能就是一直是多空呃同时去做训练
其实你把它换成只做多的话
可能
我会更好一些哈
然后我只我只能讲到这了哈
希望你能理解哈
嗯
看看大家还有没有其他的这个好的
谢谢老师哎
没事对但是我觉得呃我建议呃
因为我是觉得你可可能做了很多的这种工作哈
然后我是建议那个你是可以尝试来这个现象
对其实因为我们这个只是我们的一个呃
大家可能觉得比较难
但是
对于我们来讲
其实这个只是一个入门的一个课程哈
因为后边我们还会有很多更复更复杂的这种其他的这个课程是在这个基础上的一个延续哈
那个我们其实都没有对外都没有公开讲过
因为就是只有上过课的小伙伴才知道对哦
OK嗯
看看大家还有没有其他的问题
对大家可以在评论区打字或者是可以上麦都没问题的对
然后呢
这会可能大家没说
我就中间插一嘴哈
因为其实五月份的这个移民老师的线下课其实就是在上个周末嗯也才过去没几天
因为说实话嗯每一次来听完课后的小伙伴
包括今天我看到咱们这个这场这个就是呃来议会呢
也看到有之前来听过课的小伙伴也都在哈
对大家其实就感受会很会很清晰
就是因为这两天的内容看似是两天
但其实内容是非常的多的
而且市面上可能据我所知吧
因为我本身也是在机构出来嘛
然后据我所知的话
目前国内是没有这样像移民老师讲全站的这样的一个课程是没有的
因为对于国因为我之前也一直是在国内嘛
所以说其实感受会比较深
尤其是在机构
因为没有哪个pm会把他的全站的东西交给你的
在机构都是呃每个qr呀qd呀
大家的职能都非常的独立
因为站在机构老板的角度
他也不可能说让下面的员工是都学会了
这个人家不自己吃拍出去单干了吗
因为这个行业本身也都比较的现实对
所以说包括今天我邀请一秒是做这个
大议会呢也都是因为之前有一些小伙伴啊
跟我有沟通过
那可能后续呢
因为我平时事也比较多
就没有跟着大家去聊具体
比如说哪儿还有一些疑问
所以我觉得最好的方式呢
可能就是把一一名老师请过来
然后呢
大家有什么问题咱们就直接沟通
可能会更为直接一些对
然后的话呢
就看看今天大家这个机会也比较难得哈
然后呢
就是大家有什么问题也都可以来问到
因为说实话
我们本身不是职业干麦克这件事的
因为也不靠这个生计哈
对然后呢
就是我只能说是趁大家如果是真的想后期
往职业量化方向去走
就是趁着一名老师
他他现在还有时间和精力
愿意想这个课就真的是可以来听一听
因为如果后面他那天他不愿意讲了
就真的可能国内你打着灯笼
也不可能会有人愿意这样去讲全站的东西了
这个放在机构的话
说实话就是pm他发产品的东西
对所以就
可能哪怕你去找一个小小机构
小私募的话
你问问你花多少钱
那个pm他能愿意把他的策略交给你
也不现实
对OK我看到评论区有问题
丁老师麻烦您做一下解答吧
嗯我看到了
然后是打完标签后进行布局训练是怎样选样本
应该不是全部都用
嗯
会影响某种训练
这是这样的这个训练的时候
当然说是在训练集上来做
我训练哈
嗯
但是正常情况下呢
我们是做这个样本外的样本外来做这个by testing
就是来做这个测试
那也就是说是样本内的测试集
其实我们都不会用
就是用完全跟他无关的呃
布局来做这个呃
就是模型的这种评估啊
或者是呃做相应的这种处理啊
然后其实是样本外的样本来
阳格阳格来讲的话
对
嗯
第二个问题是
不否需要自己写石盘系统
嗯
哦
一体化哦
这个不会的这个石盘的代码
其实我们都给大家都写好了
懂
对
就是像这个第十个环节就是石盘这个推理石盘推理
因为很多时候大家是训练完之后
其实在石盘的时候他连不起来
因为这个石盘的这个还是蛮复杂的坦率讲
对
因为之前有有
这个很多小伙伴就是他其实做的也很好
但是他就是在石盘的时候他没有办法穿起来
对
所以呢
这边呢
我们会把这个石盘整个的这个推理的这个代码的逻辑都和大家讲清楚
然后代码也是所有环节的这个事
都是要给给那个要给大家的哈
对
另外我看他提到比如支持tick级别的自定义轴作因子
比划能tick其实是可以的
但是其实是如果你的交易频率比较高的话
那其实是tick级别是没有问题
但是如果你交易频率不是那么高的话
其实就没有没有就是没有没有必要在tick级别上做融产样
比如说你做这个
比如说股票啊
商品期货甚至是crypto其实也都用不到tick级的数据数据啊
那其实这个如果是做这个频率特别高的话
其实是用tick级别的数据
重采样才会有意义哈
就当然说这个我们也都会讲啊
然后我再多说几句话
因为这个大家可能对这个重采样比较问题比较多
但是其实是这样的哈
因为我们要知道我们重采样
其实目的不是为了把这个风度给的下降
让风度那个降那个下降下来
对其实主要的目的不是为了这个哈
那这个是我们的附加的价值哈
那主要其实我们追求的是
我们呃叫配线也好
叫bar也好
就是每一个那个bar内部的这个信息密度更均匀的一个问题了
那其实这个是最有最有意义的哈
并不是说我们表象上看到的这个我们要把这个往下降哈
对那其实这个我们怎么都能给他讲下来
对那但是其实我们要知道我们目的是什么
因为他和我们后面的这个特征和标签以及模型训练都是连着的啊
他不仅仅
因为每一步他之间他是有协同的
他不是完全独立的哈
你就像比如说我们在做嗯
比如说我给大家举个例子哈
比如说我们在做这个这个在做截面
因为我们现在聊的更更多的是时序哈
因为时序是基础哈
对然后时序基础打到之后
然后我们带上截面哈
比如说那截面其实很多的这个呃因子
比如说他一会有效一会没效
其实问题出在不是在因子本身上哈
跟你的计算方式
也无关哈
但其实基本上你的那个因子其实是在这个轴上是基于时间的哈
是基于时间维度
对那也就是说我们做截面
比如说要做这个阿尔法策略
对他和这个阿尔就是和你的这个嗯
整个能获利的这个风格其实是整个是有联是有联系
那也就是说你本身基于的这个贝斯烂其实是本身就没有统计意义
所以你用这个啊
呃时间轴上的基于时序
你算的一些呃这个呃数学表达
然后你在做阿尔法的时候
其实是有时有效会有时没效
对他不是说你用简单的这种条件因子
你就能够或者是非线性
你直接上非线性
他就能找到这个规律的哈
因为他你即使上了非线性
他其实也很难找到这个规律
所以呢
我们无论是时序还是截面呢
其实我们都希望
大家能够用这种重采样的这种方式哈
对因为很多其实机构也在用
只是大家都对外公开吧
对没有因为我们本身不做
我和大家没有什么冲突
所以我才直接才愿意进行分享
包括后面的一些标签的标注方式等等
其实都是呃都是
其实我们一直是我们的这种经验哈
对有很多时候其实不是说你一上来就知道的
有很多的细节和经验
其实是你在亏了很多的资金之后
慢慢的这个领悟出来的这个内容
对OK那看看大家还有没有什么问题
如果没问题的话
就可以先结束掉哈
有你你这边嗯哦OK
就看看大家还有没有什么问题
对然后呢
我最后的话
再跟大家就是补充一下
就是嗯就是咱们的这个线下课程的内容
说白了就是一套能够转肯定能实盘
落地到实盘的一个基于纯机器学习机构
级的这样的一个生产线
然后呢因为它是一个通用框架
那不管说是像crypto啊
ETF商品期货股指其实都可以直接复用对
并且是基于数学逻辑的
然后呢所以说它的解释性更好
这个呢也是之前咱们很多来上过课的一些机构的小伙伴
哎谁的那个麦没关
对可以关一下对因为国内说实话
因为我在这就不方便提名字了哈
通常国内百亿级私募的QR
包括PM也都有来听过课
呃这个名字我就不便多说了
对所以说这个是就作为机构是非常非常看重的一点
对因为大家可能现在在是就是在
在大家平时听到的可能都是一些比如说
多因子相关呀
或者说是一些复兴研报相关的
当然我不是说这个内容不好哈
当然其实包括我们之前在机构也有在用
但是呢其实这个仅仅只是整个pipeline的其中的一到两个环节
就是就是你把它做的再极致
也不可能说是会影响你这个策略能够一定做的多好
就这个大家一定要清楚就是量化它是一个系统
它不是说你只是做好一个环节两个环节就能够做到很好的
就这点非常重要
OK我看看评论区有问题
邓老师麻烦您做一下解答吧
嗯
OK看到了是哦他看过我们所有的这个视频哈
25年到现在过去一半
嗯消果桌所有内容都是我
哦是这样的哈因为我们呃这个
是上面给大家做这个演示嘛
对然后这个因为现在很多上过课的小伙伴
其实他们做的都很不错
也都拿到了很好的这个结果
因为他们呃有的时候会跟我说
有的时候会跟那个跟uni说的会更多哈
对然后基本上都有很多拿到了结果
然后有的也都直接在机构的话
他们直接就发产品了哈
对所以这个石盘是呃还是这个是嗯
和就是就是直接就能够看到的哈
对然后这是第一个问题哈
第二个问题就是呃
这个第二个问题是关于特征工程的哈
是复杂构造还是普通的这个哦
高低什么
开盘收盘哦是这样的哈
这个问题特征没有那么复杂哈
当然说我们也有呃
比如说用更高阶的这个物素数学表达啊
来做
但是其实基本上比如说开盘收盘最高最低
其实这类的呃数据其实已经够我们来用了哈
对那其实就是可以用这种方式来做
那比如说我们当然说后面也会讲到很多的这种
比如说呃基于这个呃拓扑的方式来处理这个特征的
包括呃还有一些比如说像分数节来处处理的哈
对当然说其实也都是基于这个呃
开盘收盘
然后这个
最高价最低价
因为这个是我们的基础的这个量价的这个数据嘛
对基本上是都就是无论你有上千上万的特征
其实完全都是基于他来做计算的
对
呃
还有一个小伙伴问上课前应该准备哪些统计学的知识有推荐的书籍
嗯
其实也不用太
我觉得只是对概率有初步的了解就可以
因为Uni那边呃
有那个现成的电子书
哈可以回来可以找那个Uni来要对
有那个电子书可以可以发给大家来看一下
对想想其实统计呃统计其实还是蛮有意义的
然后在这个整个的这个量化的这个呃里面
比如说像呃概率呀
统计呀
还还有一些更深的内容
其实帮我们会理解这个机器学习背后的这个逻辑啊
对嗯
嗯
这个群的问题我来回答吧
这个咱们的话呢
对没有做这种就是什么交流群
因为我说实话当然平时有很多小伙伴来家
我问我有什么交流群没有
我说实话没有
因为我觉得没必要
因为这个量化说实话
大家所谓的交流就你哪怕你在一个公司
你同事之间都不带多聊两句的
你更何况你不认识的人呢
能跟你多聊啥
那当然闲话当然可以聊
但是正儿八经的东西大家不可能聊
如果说你想了解一下课程的内容的话呢
课程的详细安排这边都是我在安排
对然后的话你可以直接联系我就可以了
对因为这种所谓的交流
我觉得片子也很多
这个就我也没法筛选
所以一直都没有那个
没有做这种什么所谓的交流群
当然咱们是每一期这个有
参客的小伙伴我会去做一个
这样就是我们每期参客的小伙伴会有一个群
因为这个大家都是见过面是认识的
所以这个是有的
因为大家后续复现过程当中
还有很多问题也都可以在群里沟通
或是直接联系到一鸣老师
就没问题的
因为上课其实包括每次我们上课到最后一鸣老师
都会说上课不是终点
因为你上了课后完之后呢
还有一个复现的过程
那复现过程当中呢还有很多的细节问题
这个是每个人的问题会不一样
所以后续的话呢咱们的这个课后有问题
都可以直接问到一鸣老师
因为自己如果说去琢磨的话
可能一个问题就得卡几个月
这中间的时间成本和精力成本太高了
对然后大致的情况就是这样子
对然后看看大家
还没有其他的问题
有问怎么联系到
然后这是
现在屏幕上显示的是Uni的那个微信
我简单介绍一下Uni
因为Uni是
是我之前
那个美国的一个同志的
学生
对然后Uni本身在国内
其实他比较低调
因为他之前是在一家百亿私募
做QR
对然后他是这个
但是说现在已经出来了
对然后这个
大家有很多问题可以直接问他
其实他本身也很厉害
Uni对
一鸣老师我看到评论区还有一个问题
对你可以解答一下
那是成交额的轴
对
我介绍原理
原理其实就是我们用
比如说你达到多
达到多少的这个预值
然后我们来生成我们的这个
生成我们的K线
对
其实原理比较简单
OK那大家有什么
再有什么问题就可以
这个联系Uni
他会帮大家
对大家直接对接
对大家如果后续有相关课程的
问题都可以联系我
然后一鸣老师目前在国内的
这个课程也就也都只有我这边
在安排就其他可能会有一些
人说相关的基本上
都是骗子就也不希望大家上当受骗
对所以大家有相关的问题
联系我就可以了然后呢
大概今天大家如果没有问题的话呢
我们就先暂时到这里了
好吧然后后续的话呢就
大家就咱们随时沟通
OK感谢一鸣老师
今天特地抽时间出来给咱们做
这样的一个答疑哈然后呢
小伙伴们大家也都希望大家
不管是听课与否也都希望大家之后的
这个交易之路都越来越好
好吧然后呢咱们今天就先到这里了
然后再见谢谢大家再见
拜拜